hello my friend
there's no need to yell
you're basically arguing that not knowing different countries within
Europe is equivalent to not knowing different states within America
and I would say that the two are not comparable at all
of course there are cultural differences within the United States
and these differences are more visible the further that
point A is from point B
but if we equate the states of the USA to countries in Europe
then the countries of Europe are far more linguistically
culturally and even ethnically diverse on a state to state basis
you said something along the lines of
“let's assume each country within Europe has a different culture and history”
we don't need to assume
the history of countries within Europe spans centuries to millennia
which is why you can drive 15 minutes into another country
and be met by a population that speak a completely different language
and have different cultural practices
countries of Europe are far more linguistically diverse
as in most countries in Europe have a different set of official languages
many if not most of these languages
belong to different branches of the Indo-European language family
and are usually not even mutually intelligible
and then there are even some languages like Hungarian or Finnish
who have completely different origins
now you could fly from one side of the US to the other
from New York to California
and while there may be some cultural differences
you still rely on English as the primary language for communication
whereas in Europe
if you're an Italian travelling to something close by like France
you best hope that someone speaks Italian or that
you know French
and then of course
there is also religious diversity
there are countries in Europe like Bosnia
which are majority Muslim
I do find it funny that your example that you used was
comparing Netherlands, Luxembourg
Germany and Belgium
countries that are geographically close and share official languages
Europe like much of the world
works on a cultural and linguistic continuum
and so the further you move away from point a to point B
the more differences you're going to notice
also join me on TikTok Live today by clicking this link
we're playing guess the Extinct Religion
see you there